what's up everybody its Mary with Rob
handler hey how's it going around it's
going good we are playing a really weird
game that I saw and I just couldn't say
no - it's called FRU I think what makes
it interesting is that it's utilizing
the Kinect what's a Kinect Rob I don't
know it's archaic device I don't think
I've heard anyone use a Kinect it's such
a long time but these developers are
using it in a really unique way where
they're basically it's a two-player game
and as you can see Rob's on the Kinect
and I'm I'm going to be playing the
platformer oh so here he's creating the
stand for me thank you rob
so I can get through level I think it's
a really unique concept and you know the
Kinect was really never oh yeah I need
you to you know what put your whole body
in there yeah arms too skinny I need
your fat body thank you now I need you
to not be here and not be there with
your fat body
now I need your fat body give me that
hey you're gonna not say that the whole
time right think more body come over
here is shooting you I'm a hair I'm in
the game okay more body thank you I feel
like you haven't raced you haven't
picked up how this here my child
Here I am to save the day oh I just
realized something
oh my god don't kill me oh well this is
just a big troll no no so I don't want
you there because I fall through Oh see
I feel like you don't understand now
what's that totem pole thing nothing but
so you create but you also take away so
I want this here I don't want you there
does that make sense and I want you over
here very yeah that's the stuff put your
big head over there there you go this is
this is awesome for like just - peeps -
to play and enjoy together I'm gonna
fall through the world oh wait I want to
yeah you're fine you idiot oh so I need
your borrower here then right give me or
do I just go to the right I know there's
a lift here is there a lift put your
whole body over there
it's kind of tweaking out good like move
your bod all the way over here thank you
oh it's a ladder you're kind of blocking
it all right your bot is blocking it
yeah oh my god
all right here we go my bod is what it
is no no okay so I need you to lean yeah
that's the owner huh
he's actually kind of tough ah you have
to like position all right so they're
aware there must be another one over
damn it all right sorry hand tight oh
there it is okay right so move your knee
yeah you know this kind of reminds me of
is all right that's all you oh dang look
at this yeah that's the stuff nice this
is awesome what a cooling oh there's
weight uh where am I going
well I think you should get that thing
what oh yeah ding that Boris I think
there's that that's like what hidden
hidden gems I hate that line hidden boar
head it was so much potential for the
Kinect and like they just did it there
wasn't enough cool things to make it
worth it yeah they're there I see I see
a platform nice nice pose by the way
okay thanks
I like what's going on here like how you
go the extra mile
okay so that whole thing yes thank you
all right now what I don't know I can
see your knee is a platform cool okay so
I gotta gather way get out of the way
all right well there's I bet there's
some know what I save you want to okay
so head to the layout down all right now
don't know don't cover this platform
yeah there it is
okay but can ya keep going going keep
going yeah Oh sick all right
whoo my body is showing you shoved away
shrubbery trim that geez I know sweat
already
all right you feel like you're working
out tad tad oh I'm actually climbing
your bod ha ha can you lift me like a
put your body in your yeah oh wait yeah
okay yeah this already [ __ ] [ __ ] me
gently oh this is like some giant movie
like Iron Giant
thank you time hit the help out the Iron
Giant was way more gentle than this man
on the end he had a friggin door and
lasers oh he was cool alright so this is
where you don't but I think there's
there's even this is a hole um I need
you be like wider you mean like this
see ya look I'm in your body genius
connect good Oh tight alright yeah nice
Freddie don't want happen I need a
second hand wait
okay go oops sorry little a hook height
night
alright ready uh yeah oh is this because
I called you fell there you're bought
out of the way okay all right now deck
duck down
wait why was Bob I'm confused
your body removes that area I thought
you I thought you like wanted that no I
don't want that okay
don't want that so duck down like get
away from me and then go to the other
way yeah get to that other pillar that's
the stuff I can't change everything way
your dude girl looks like um she kind of
looks weird
I'm gonna be honest with you like a fox
head it's what sorry I wanted to see
it's a table right it's a little girl
wearing a fox mask I have no idea the
lore what cure potties hilarious donor I
don't want you there yeah and then need
you somewhere else I love it are you on
your knees right now I am on my knees
all right okay cool
wow there's oh wait did you see the
Boar's Head there's a secret I did so
what I don't know how I'm gonna get it
because your heads in the way awful
noise good job
come on here sweating what doing a lot
of yoga moves um that was your fault
were you I'm not sure it alright let's
see okay I'm supposed to go through it
but I got a jump in between your legs or
something do you know what I mean you
can do right okay do you see it I'm
saying I'd be wider
all right I think we got ourselves in a
predicament here
well I only need you on the sanding I
always make things more complicated yeah
I think you're no I need you get out of
that way yeah now get back come back to
me y'all y'all all the way oh that's
gonna okay I'm okay
no get out of the way thank you now get
in the way you mean like this she has
all the way strange little Buddha okay
so I want to be on these stairs careful
you will erase these stairs so stay away
from me
oh of course there is all right let's
get let's get difficult careful Shh oh
man that was rad this games awesome
just a little tentacle arm mmm I wonder
if that's a save warhead see it where to
the right um under you so I need you to
get out of this area think yah yah yah
yah yah yah yah
you're like a benevolent B's they don't
know what to do
get away from me you're not the Iron
Giant at all I'm like a good cop back up
you're a dick giant man the connect you
are sweaty dude it's so hot in here the
sweaty giant was white sweat would show
up dreamworks presents the sweaty giant
you're creating problems i feel like i
could solve these without you oh is that
so no good
I was wrong
good I feel like I'm at your whim here
like I I live and die based on you and
how nice you want to be I don't like it
all right so I need to go through your
arm there yeah so I'll just fall okay
you see it yeah that's the stuff we'll
just go now oh this is a wall nice nice
oh nice
in out in and it was the best one yet
on the fly he's my body on the fly the
sweaty giant alright alright so I don't
need you there a second one oh my god I
don't need you on the bottom one after
after I so now I don't need you there
anymore so now I need you on the top
yeah yeah ooh what is it's a secrets
there once was up run sweaty giant was a
sweaty giant he loved his people
Oh story Oh
what sorry let me lower Rob's mic god
this habit is you're uncovering this
story get you get there there once was a
weird guy with big ears he he had no
penis that's not the story that's not
the story at all is you oh my god oh my
god is this your mother
my mommy okay so I think I know you need
to do you need to light all of them at
the same time oh [ __ ] I didn't notice I
was doing that yeah so now your head
raise your up you mean like that yeah
you look you look fantastic
Oh what does it say thinking of their
beauty is incomparable I mean I don't
know about you but dude is so ugly this
guy oh your water what oh this is where
really man I wish we just skip ahead wow
you got a little spin loose me that's
great can I come out you like a dolphin
I'm like a giant whale swimming my body
yeah I yeah I don't know if you can see
my swim animation super cute
Oh oh dude this is great all right now
we have to go with it I am one with a
dolphin
give us a big wave I got you oh you're
making things I don't like no I don't
want that
come here women like the honey that's
like a gal go mix Jesus all right well
we'll just do it
oh this is me quick picture it's got
razor sharp gene how are we supposed to
have sex with that Oh
keep me safe keep me safe in your liquid
body move slowly move slowly to the no
oh you know what you're not as fast as
you think you are - swimming in the sea
okay so I got to get through there so I
need you to be I really look like inside
oops what a reflection of who you are
hey yeah yeah yeah yeah that's stuff
whoa oh do I not want you there and I'll
just fall right we know no no no like
remove your arm you're I'm not sure oh
yeah yeah yeah and then I'll just swim
out you know who else did it the sweaty
giant I'm made of water don't you get it
once was a girl met a swim junior huh he
was pretty gross no he was also kind of
a dick huh but she needed him to get
through a series of puzzles
with razor-sharp teeth wait no patience
isn't my virtue just like the way any
isn't yours all right so where am I okay
I got it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah nice
we're doing pretty good I think we're
really smart jeez can you stand I just
keep forgetting I can do that like like
oh okay
so you have to make a break in your body
so I can get through there
sick nope all right so what's where am I
going
yep yah yah yah yah yah whoa easy there
tiger
I'll stay in the safety of your innards
keep oh I gotta get out of the way yeah
the connect okay okay
sang did you say sang I did the nude
dang you're welcome I'm floating in your
body
whoo whoa there spiked OHS look at that
okay that's weird it didn't light up
shouldn't it light up put your whole
body maybe everything maybe okay so I
think I get it
move all the way to the right again or
this over here
Oh Noel oh yeah and I'll jump over to
you
well you're blocking again sorry oh my
god there look at all these spikes
you're like a dick you're a sweaty giant
sweaty jerk oh there we go there we go
slow down slow down the buzz oh no
stepping it up aren't you FRU oh that's
right this is actually an x-ray machine
and we're learning what Rob's made out
of that's why ever launched straight up
nothing but venus flytraps
all right I may need your whole body
Bailey and then dinner go go go go go go
go go Wow it's a whoa go go go I was
excited okay so I think I have to jump
over your bod into more of your boss get
there oh I see keep going I might kill
you
no I think you're fine okay so I want to
jump over that mom so you gotta guide me
I'm not sure oh yeah
I'm not sure what you're supposed to do
it because there's spikes all the way
through here we'll just draw so there's
spikes all the way under here we'll just
walk 300 you're smarter than me now let
me know where the spikes are so you
don't kill me upon return okay okay
nice thanks that's great
same I might need let me check ahead oh
my god what that's so dangerous it's
pretty safe oh here's all the bad stuff
could you do some Tris is mad you have
more bad stuff right here Oh bad
I'm sorry a sec okay so now I can
probably make this down drop onto my
back okay okay now crawl forward okay
that's better watch out okay so now
where do I need to go now you're gonna
go up here a lot of back stuff here you
don't oh my god you don't want to jump
up right here no I need to get in that
square see it but you can't okay so do
it okay I don't know what to do
to see this oh it's a wall I wasn't
thinking I was thinking not so can I go
can I get through any other way
take me back sweaty giant all right now
I think we need to go all the way back
I'll [ __ ] that
okay you got there I can
you overestimate my swimming of hotbar
know so those are spiky oh whoa right so
I'm gonna jump I think I make that jump
okay so I don't want your help all right
so now Oh careful
so you want to jump over this uh okay
wait wait wait wait I gotta get here
[ __ ]
got it got it I mean if you look so cool
oh whoa Oh what's hungry all right so
you're gonna need to like move from the
yeah go go go go go go go go go go good
luck all right oh you got away you may
have yet no you got take a break yeah
cuz you can you can get at all yeah yeah
you're right you can get out of my space
it's like so why don't we get great we
gotta get to these levels right great
get out of my face oh I heard your mic
yeah oh okay I'm going nice go for it Oh
God
I see you're trying to get over here up
um you know like reno911.com that like
makes all the signage --is and he
doesn't like really flamboyantly dangle
here like let me help you
hey that's my job I don't even need you
do it come on breaks come back sweaty
giant I need you you're gonna I mean you
really need someone to catch you that's
right so wait I don't okay but I don't
want to land in those spikes so awful
careful young dude try okay oh okay okay
awesome that was awesome
I actually super impressed with this
well I work you mean what a great idea
and it's really fun like this isn't just
a good idea it's like really
well-executed and it's fun as hell and
yeah yeah women the English Channel here
well okay so oh [ __ ] I should have swam
all right I'm gonna do it this time go
Oh haha I'm a dolphin
go easy dolphin oh all right I need you
to give me a bit perspective let me show
you what we're working with here
yeah these arms here that one right here
does that go all the way to the end oh
[ __ ]
if you raise your hand I can jump into
your hand like yeah yeah yeah but then
avoid those spikes where your neck is
nice nice nice there's a there's one
over here now oh don't worry I'm sorry
the Tesla's I'm just a dolphin you're
the mastermind here yeah yeah yeah oh
god I'm scared here we go
I'm sorry god damn it I'm sorry your
codes are so beautiful god you're so
beautiful oh [ __ ] I have to think that
I'm like I now took a brain fart
this is the this is the puzzle for smart
people raise your hand got it and then
give a gap where your neck is when your
neck fat is there had it before
yeah iiiiii oh we go together I
yeah you have to get it this time just
really rude oh I did don't yell at me I
jump into my head alright uh one pretty
better just give me less neck fat if you
can yeah
okay I think I can make that oh god I'm
scared
no cuz like yeah okay I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do it
nice all right careful with that
shoulder gap there there we go nice all
right cool there's a ruler rule this
rulers beauty did not all this tolerate
out of your mind highlight them don't
you more attractive people in this one
oh yeah those people are stunning
they're so hot where's the other one
stomp it you know boy it's so dumb
alright no where's this there's more
poses I know I can I do this I want to
do this let me do this
where's the third your only time to
shine where's the third there now
where's it Oh
oh so you gotta like elongate your body
see that right go oh you're so beautiful
to it you had to keep it you're to hold
it alright that was through it's a fork
connect it's freaking awesome that was
funny what a weird game what a great
game for Kinect you guys like that you
can pick it up on connect it is
available as of July 13th and that was
great it was a good game you have a good
time Rob I did had an excellent time I
had an excellent time as well and thank
you guys for watching if you're on
YouTube please don't forget to Like and
subscribe because it helps us make more
silly things like this I want to keep
playing let's just see what this is
I have no idea like there's just new
mechanics every time oh man you know
what this [ __ ] even home are you the
keymaster because I am the gatekeeper
dude this this just threw in the twister
element you know what I mean yeah can I
look in miserable
hard remove your knee Yas dang remove
see it this is the title I know I'm just
so this yep
so put it back and remove oh man alright
I'm gonna end this cuz it's like a 30
minute video but yeah proof thank you
guys for watching and we will see you
guys again leave with a pose rub show
them all that good stuff
Hot Stuff hot stuff new pose work it
work it work it work it work it girl
work it girl